he's a one-man fast break whether he
consider the offense or whether it's
adhesions pushing the pace you get the
Hawkins set up the same little just
bumming his way in his regained the lead
one this is fun shots are gone good pace
to the game there's little now it hangs
he scores he bounds nice hands up he
made the defenders think he was going to
shoot a jump shot look at the pace by
Carolina they're running for after a
made basket
Haho they get out and they run beyond
the arc cam Johnson lines it up too
strong little quiet high for the final
scene quickly the hot shooting in the
first half that's cooled off to the
second half little girls go fits in
left-handed scoop by the seer little is
good you want to see that if you're not
on the fan because you only have two
free throw you wonder when fatigue
becomes a factor in age he turns it over
look at the counted Man 1 for the seer
little this reaction you love this
passion of your a Carolina fan you
believe in the team you want them to
play with that kitchen is going to their
match and their trap to try to get
Carolina to shoot it quick
and they are going to shoot it quick and
they're going to knock it down as little
sense thank you very much the board that
was the right play from the girl right
there you got a little bit of space you
just need to knock about two-handed
flush Nasir little just to the basket
want to leave huh do fulfill those guys
have to look Carolina's hallway you're
not just gonna be chatting around as
brother's saying something Richie McGill
also had a major mechanic let a little
turnaround Jam great steals artists that
was a long to it is scored for Noel they
will take a look at it and it's little
on the other end the answer quickly find
the heels Johnson up ahead transition
three Nasir little is foul
[Applause]
we'll be white walls moving around the
perimeter this is little for three
Washington's made seven threes here's
little inside again he caught a DP no
one's going to go up there in that
territory once you gonna get a little
bit of confidence they're gonna keep
knocking down shots so you think of
North Carolina players going to knock
down the shot in the paint like they're
blocking shots on the scene by little
and white up ahead Brooks running the
floor and finds the to keep knocking
down shots oh you think of North
Carolina players gonna knock down the
shot in the paint like they're blocking
shots on this scene by little and white
up ahead Brooks running the floor good
look right there by Washington that's
what you want don't get frustrated six
minutes left you still have to make a
run you're getting good looks his little
takes the contact and still scores this
is just this is patience with in a
fast-paced offense no transference and
it speaks to the ability of Mike Hopkins
and his staff and Cameron dollar dollar
if Dave
[Applause]
Williams will dump it inside like smooth
getting the roll its Nasir little T from
downtown Dunbar the drive couldn't
finish it for the left hand
he's got by little size advantage look
out in transition little with the left
hand and the foul part forgot him
initially they had this size advantage
see you can line it up right there when
you watch the defender Harper trying to
get in this way no contest go into the
basket